e
e e
okay folks
selling now is like bolting the bond
after the hores left right okay couple
of things before we
start one is when I get into the
classroom before you do I have to go
through this checklist to make sure I've
got every item checked off so get I have
to come in here I have to first I have
to uh log into my NYU account otherwise
I can't get to my H Drive and that
requires you go through through the
two-stage Pro which means if I forget my
phone I'm screwed right I have to go
back
up second I've got to State the zoom
going so that requires another set of
don't don't ask me why and why ask you
again are you really you I say I'm me
and then it lets me in then once I open
the zoom I have to hit the record button
because that's how you get the recording
so first I want to make sure that all of
this stuff is actually working in
practice because I did put up the links
to the class from zoom and I put up the
downloadable video and audio of
Wednesday's lecture as well as a YouTube
version of the lecture has anybody tried
those links to their
work has anybody tried the links and
they don't work okay one thing I I this
might be a little tricky but if you
don't if you're not from Stern how many
of you are not Stern students okay you
might find that you might not be getting
the emails I don't know whether you are
but if you're not getting the emails
it's usually because the emails I don't
put in a list of email addresses it goes
to an alias that's maintained by the
school with Google Groups which is
connected to your
Albert which which tell and the two
don't talk to each other very well and
if you have an NYU email address it
sometimes can't find you so today after
the class when you get the email I'll
send you a link on how if you a non
Stern student you can get that Stern
email address which is actually assigned
to you the minute you got into the class
and you will need it for other stuff
that you access it
Stu so Brian came up before the
class and he asked about the big
question that should be all on all of
your minds today was an interesting day
right and I'm using the word interesting
the way the Chinese use it in a curse
which is may you live in interesting
times it's not a good thing know we all
want to actually live in boring times
interesting is not always upset there's
a lot of downside and what happened over
the weekend that's kind of upended at
least portions of the
world okay so deep seek came out so
what's different about deep seek as
opposed to all this AI stuff keeps
coming
out okay Friday if I to the company I
was going to Value tomorrow was going to
be Invidia I've decided to put it off
for a week cuz I'm in a little bit of
turmoil and I haven't had a chance to
revisit the Nvidia story see why would
the Nvidia story change because of
something that happened over a weekend
on Friday the story I'd have told for
NVIDIA is it makes these AI chips that
are incredibly powerful without which
you can't build AI systems and to the
extent that you believe AI is going to
be this big
business a Nvidia is an integral part so
the entire valuation is built on that
premise of how big will the a market get
how much will people spend on chips and
Nvidia will be the dominant player in
that
gy and deep seek basically appended that
story right basically it said look a lot
I mean it might still be true that for
and I think this is still going to be
true that for a portion of a you will
need the Invidia chips but your grocery
store trying to figure out what people
are going to buy off your shelves you
don't might not need high-tech AI you
might be able to get and let's face it a
lot of the AI products and solutions are
trivial products and solutions and deep
seek says you you know what you can get
by with the chips you have not the
potato chips in know but you know what
I'm talking about the Intel chips the
AMD
chips this strikes at the heart of the
Invidia story right because the minute
this comes into the story it means your
potential Market becomes less than what
you thought it was even if you thought
AI was going to be successful the market
gets smaller that is going to have
ripple effect we talked about stories
and numbers the story had a fundamental
shift today doesn't mean you can't tell
a new story and a new
value but you got to be okay with that
this can happen to your company right
you can value the company and somewhere
in the middle of the semester something
can happen oh my God hopefully it won't
be the end of your company 23 and me and
somebody hacks into the computer steals
all the genetic stuff the company's dead
that's a story break this is a story
change is NVIDIA worth less today than
it was three days ago yeah
absolutely is it priced less today than
it was 3 days ago absolutely in fact
today Invidia lost how much of Market
Gap do you
know about $800
billion it lost the equivalent of the
entire African Equity
Market or the entire midle and Equity
Market in one day if you don't count a
ramco that's a big loss so what's the
question we asking in valuation we agree
both agree both sides agree that the the
number attached to Nvidia should stop
the question I'm going to ask in the
next week and this is going to be my
next week's assignment is given what
this has done to my story what is NVIDIA
worth now and what I'm looking for is
the value dropped by 800 billion a
trillion 600 billion 4 because if we
drop only 400 billion the Market's down
800 billion this might be actually a
good time to buy
it's a good time to ask the
question but that's going to be my
exercise starting tomorrow I did promise
you evaluation of the week so you're
saying what are we going to Value this
week you're going to answer the question
I the one question I absolutely hate to
be asked on CNBC but I will get asked
every single time every time I go on you
know what I'm get what I get asked right
what do you think about the market do
you think it's in a
bubble I'm going to give you my answer
to that question at the start of this
year in evaluation of the S&P 500 I'm
going to do an intrinsic valuation of
the index I'm going to give you my
finding on it my keyword is my and
you're going to take my spreadsheet I've
done the dirty work for you and disagree
with me say I don't like your growth
rate I don't like this I don't do
whatever you feel comfortable doing but
use the Google shared spreadsheet to
enter what you discovered to be the
value of the index let's start big right
this will make you the most s s after
the least sought after person at your
Thanksgiving dinner most sought after if
everybody says what do you think the
market will do now you can say give some
deep thoughts Le sought after because
nobody wants to talk about the market
they want to talk about the turkey that
too is okay right so that's going to be
the valuation of the week but trust me
next week you're getting Invidia and
let's look at the Ripple effects Invidia
is directly in the in the Target zone
right chips you don't need the chips
what else has been a effect what what
else you know what what else goes in the
AI architecture in addition to
chips well that's I think peripheral
still because those are
products power because the story with AI
is you need these incredibly power
hungry data centers and there's a
company called Constellation Energy take
a look at it and what does it do it
values gone up in the last couple years
because it provides the power to these
data centers it's been slammed today
think of this if you think in terms of
concentric circles
the immediate effect is going to be on
the air architecture
companies why because all those the next
layer is going to be on the companies
that have spent money in the
architecture mostly big tech companies
half of the money spent on AI chips came
from the big tech companies they were
spending on AI chips why because they
hope and pray none of them is making
money on actually Air Products and
solutions but because they think the
market is Big they've spent the money
and now they probably looking back at
remember last week sella was asked how
much he SP a and he said 80 billion I'm
okay with that he might not be okay with
that
today but you're not going to get the
money back the good news if you're a
Microsoft stockholder is hey you can
afford to lose 80 billion not even
notice the difference right they have
150 billion it's not going to break or
make or break but there's going to be
some you know buyers remorse you say
look we shouldn't have done that which
will be lead to but there's a there's
another effect that I think people
haven't thought through this whole game
is about providing AI products and
solutions and I think deep seek has now
made that reach even greater more of us
are going to be able to get these but it
comes with the catch there'll be less
money in this
business because it's going to be easy
to provide these products and solutions
the old game was hey we're going to
we're meta you're AWS you're going to
spend the money on AI chips and then you
will have the special that you and only
you can deliver and you're going to
charge a premium
price that's going to be much more
difficult now so in a strange way deep
seek has opened up the eye business
we're far more likely to see ey products
and services as consumers but it it
might have commoditized the business at
the same time which means there's a lot
less money to be made has everything
been adjust no right now it's a start of
the process the markets are just
confused right they're just selling
whatever they're told to sell but this
is the time to think about value we'll
talk about value in the face of
uncertainty so pick Constellation Energy
pick Amazon and that's going to be the
exercise I go through is I'm going to
start with Nvidia the direct hits and
then we'll go on concentric circles and
then ask the bigger question what does
this mean for AI as a business going
forward it's going to be a bigger
business but a less monetizable
one so I'm going to let that roll I'm
going to take a long walk without my
iPhone let that roll around and see what
that plays out but that'll come next
week but you don't have to wait for me
to come up with it you can start
thinking about it because there are
these Ripple effects that are going to
play
out today I want to start with um your
project I kind of talked about this but
before I talk about the project I first
want to say talk in terms of what goes
into your grading because what will not
go into your grading I don't take
attendance
there's no participation trophies so I
don't add points for
participation so I want you to
participate but for the right reasons do
it because you feel you have you know
you have you have you have a question to
ask your grade will be based on three
quizzes and a final exam the three
quizzes are each worth 10% a piece the
final exam is 30% the quiz dates are in
your syllabus so you can check out the
dates you're saying what if I cannot
make a quiz I have an interview I know
life gets in the way if if you do miss a
quiz here's what's going to happen the
10% on that quiz will get moved to the
remaining quizzes and the final exam let
me repeat that again because I know even
though I'm saying this now I will get an
email every week for the what happens if
I miss a quiz here's what happens if you
miss the first quiz that 10% will be
proportionally allocated which means
your second quiz will now be worth 12%
the thirdd quiz will be worth 12 and the
final will be worth 36 if you miss the
second quiz that 10% will go into the
third quiz he saying why this uted
exercise because I've been teaching 40
years and I've see how I've seen how you
guys game the system you know but they
why I don't let you kind of reweight
everything right because you get
strategic quiz missing that you do
really well in the first two quizzes
you're going to be tempted to miss the
third quiz why because it makes your
first two quizzes waited more not with
me it's always going to be the future so
it's okay to miss a quiz if you take all
three quizzes there's a bonus I will
offer you which is I will take your
worst quiz and I will throw it out and
rewe the other quizzes actually I won't
throw it out I'll give your worst quiz
the same average score you got on the
other two quizzes so just take an EXT
extreme example you get 10 on quiz one
you get zero on quiz two and you go back
to doing 10 what happened you're you're
bipolar and that was your bad time and
the zero was when when when the bad part
hit here's what I'm going to do I am
going to take your zero and replace with
the 10 why because you got 10 on the
other two quizzes and and I'll bring in
also your final exam so basically I'm
going to give you an escape hatch on one
bad quiz don't ask me what happens if
you have two bad quizzes you can work
out the math the escape hatch gets
smaller and smaller you had three bad
quizzes it got really tiny and you're
elephant trying to get through a mouse
hole and I'll let you figure out what to
do
next the quizzes are open
book open
notes and open iPad displays and the
reason is very simple it's open book
open notes my notes are probably all on
some digital device for you right most
of you haven't printed it so if you have
an iPad a computer with their slides you
want to look at it fine but you cannot
open up Excel on your laptop not because
you're going to get an advantage but
because you have 200 people with laptops
open to excel God Only Knows what'll
happen in that room and it things that
bad things happen so it's open book open
Notes open device to get to your
slides and I will write the problems in
such a way it's not convoluted that you
need an Excel spreadsheet so none of the
problems would test you on can you
project things out for the next 10 years
it'll be built around doing numbers in
your head so this is really about
testing you on whether you can apply the
concepts you do in
class so those are the three quizzes
what's on the final
everything it'll cover the entire class
which is a lot but by then you've
already got three quizzes you can in a
sense at least build on what you've
learned so if you miss a quiz my advice
is take the material you missed in that
quiz and get up to speed on that that
because eventually you will need it he's
saying what about the other
40% it's for your project and that's
what I want to spend a few minutes on
Project is basically a group
project so they saying who should be in
your group you pick your group I'm not
putting you in a group because that way
you will come to me and say I don't like
the group you put me in you live with
the group you pick you self police the
group what do what does that mean every
group has a few people who kind of
lag you figure out how to get them
online because in a sense you get a
collective grade so that's a lot of
responsibility is saying but this is the
way the business World Works you're
often caring people on the group now you
figure out a way to get their attention
make them watch The Godfather especially
the scene where the horse's head gets
cut and put on the know essentially say
bad things are coming at if you don't
keep up but I'll let you figure out what
those bad things will be right so you
pick your group the group can be up to
eight
people and you don't need to meet very
often but with eight people you carrying
a lot more people right so you got to
make the trade-off do I want to go your
group has to be at least four up to
eight so what you decide to do again I
will leave the choice to you and here's
what you're going to do each of you is
going to pick a company to
Value you can pick whatever company want
public or
private if it's a private business just
make sure you can get the financials for
that business if it's a family business
make sure you're still talking to your
your family if not your family business
going to be tough to value and make sure
you're going to continue to talk to your
family after you value the business so
all those things have to be juggled in
there but if it's a private business
that's fine too but I will impose an
overarching group constraint and I'll
come back to what I mean by you know
with the which
is when you pick your companies as a
group group at least one of your
companies has to be a money losing
company I want you to face the pain of
dealing with losses and what to do about
them because there's no escape hatch
right easy escape hatch in terms just
increase the profits everything's only
okay if you have losses you got to
figure it out at least one and that
money losing company can be a young
startup it can be a declining company
either and I'm going to Define money
losing as this company had negative
operating income in the most recent year
not net income negative operating
okay at least one of your companies has
to have high growth potential hope more
in revenues than in earning so you're
picking a business in some growth
business I'm not going to put some
artificial number like 25% just pick a
Growth Company you'll know it when you
see it third at least one of these
companies has to be a non us
company and I'd like you to Value the
company in the local currency so you
want to pick a Brazilian company for
godsakes valued in R and if you want to
value in dollars give me a really good
good reason why because I want you to
get comfortable working with different
currencies and
finally at least one of these companies
be Service Company that's an easy one to
meet because 90% of companies out there
provide
services now notice only your group has
to meet these constraints can you have
one company that meets all these
constraints yeah you can find one money
losing
foreign company which
is meets three or you say why would I do
that this is your punishment on that
fifth person who wants to join your
group say we're not we're all going to
Value nice money-making mature companies
you get the money losing high growth
foreign company and let them carry the
burden but I'll give you if you really
want to understand valuation you're
going to learn more about valuation
dealing with these difficult companies
than with the easy
ones
so that's my only constraint my other
piece of advice of the project is don't
wait too long you know what I mean by
wait L long don't go like Hamlet you
know I don't like that company I'll try
not it's week five and you still have
picked a company it's getting late in
the game pick a company and if you want
to change your mind you're perfectly
okay changing your mind I'm I I there's
a master list that I will send you where
once you've told me you're in a group I
also ask you a company so go enter the
company in the master list I want to see
the company so I'm aware of what's being
valued in the class and again if you
want to change your mind change the
company I'm okay with that so make sure
you visit the master list tell me
whether you're in a group and pick a
company and try to do it as soon as you
can you're going to be doing a valuation
of the
company and that valuation I'm going to
give you a one time freebie which is
Midway through the semester I think the
actual date
is no why it's clicking
through on March 29th you can send in
your intrinsic valuation which might
just be a spreadsheet it's a one time
deal because I would check through that
spreadsheet and not tell you whether the
valuation is right I don't have that
power but I can tell you it's whether it
is an internal inconsistency whether
glitches you need to fix it's completely
optional so if you feel Comfort
completely comfortable saying I know
what I need to know and I'm going to do
it on turn in the final valuation on May
5th it's your valuation but if you want
to take advantage of that mid semester
feedback the entire project is due on
May 5th the last day of class before
5:00 p.m. that
day any questions on the project yes go
ahead yeah did everybody get the
question let's say he picks Netflix can
somebody else pick so don't look through
the list it doesn't matter last semester
I had 11 people valuing Netflix
seven people valuing
Spotify five people I think value
basically I can tell what you do in your
spare time by the kind of companies you
pick to Value draft gangs
Netflix Crispy Cream used to be a very
big favorite you know basically you
haven't picked a company you're sitting
there eating a Crispy Cream and watching
Netflix and I have to pick a company
look at the Box Crispy Cream that's a
good enough company okay so I have know
I it's perfectly okay you know why it's
perfectly okay you think seven people
Bing Netflix come up with the same value
there's zero chance of that happening so
you can pick the same company you're
going to tell different
stories and at the end you're going to
see the differences and you can see why
the differences happen
yes it's an interesting question what
makes for a non us company the easy
answer is it's Incorporated traded does
its business so is Alibaba is
Alibaba for until very recently was a
us incor a US traded company right was
traded in the NASDAQ incorporate in the
Cayman Islands but it's a Chinese
company so cut to the heart of where the
company is it might be incorporate in
trade in a strange place but that'll
determine the non us company so if you
want to pick a Chinese company that is
listed on the NASDAQ for whatever reason
it might be corporate governance reasons
Capital raising reasons it's still a
Chinese company
any other questions
yes God help you with a Russian company
I'm s I'm sorry I I no and I'll tell you
what the biggest challenge is going to
be when you value shares in a publicly
traded company what are you implicitly
doing an intrinsic valuation you're
acting like your part owner of the
company right and already there a
Russian company things get
shaky I'll tell you person and this is
personal pain coming through I used to
own shares in a company called luk
oil I thought I own shares in a company
called luk oil let me pre prefer it's a
Russian Oil Company actually is a
company that I likeed right you know I
wanted to get an oil company in a part
of the world where people don't don't
really throw it was trading at a re what
I thought was it was an undervalued
company and it did really well for me
until one day it just dis appeared from
my portfolio went to zero overnight do
you know what
happened Russia invaded Ukraine and the
company the stock I bought is actually
not on the Russian exchange it was on
the London exchange because it was I
said this is good I buy it on a exchange
and I'm comfortable with then the
sanctions get imposed and the London
exchange essentially
disappears value zero I called my broker
and I said what the heck do I do now it
says zero he said well you can't get
money back on the London exchange but if
you really wanted to lay a claim there's
a pathway and I said what's the pathway
he said you should fly to
Russia and lay claim on your shares and
I said will I come back and they said no
and so it's at zero I'm not planning to
get it back the prom with Russian
companies will be are you Russian are so
you feel comfortable about the
ownerships taken the company going to
value
okay that's fine so if you want to Value
Russian company that you feel
comfortable that your shares actually
lay claim on the because I don't think
it's a problem actually putting a value
on a luk oil or a sever stall because
they're Steel company Oil Company it's
when you get from that value to value
per share that you're going to run into
these issues but if you feel comfortable
enough I'm perfectly okay in fact I
would love to see a Russian company
actually
value it doesn't matter because what are
you going to do you're going to it's not
the value that I'm looking for the final
part of this project after you value the
company and you priced it is you're
going to compare those numbers to the
market
price right as long as they're in
dollars you do everything in dollars you
want to do everything in Rubles do it in
Rubles you're not making recommendations
to me you're making recommendations for
yourself to decide whether to buy or
sell that's the end of the end game for
the project is keep that in mind this is
not an exercise and coming up with a
number it's an exercise and coming with
the number that you can act on okay so
that's going to be the final part you're
going to Value the company then you're
going to price it and then you're going
to put out a
recommendation which
is buy or sell don't weasel out don't
give me weak buy weak sell semi strong
buy you either buy or sell right so I'm
not going to let you get all those
layers of I don't feel like doing it so
I'm just going to say week by so take it
take it I will let you hold an stream
cases but I will call you a chicken when
you do that so be ready for that but
that's going to be the end game for the
project yes and somebody back there had
a question I just okay any other
questions on the group
yes that's objective for the project the
quizzes and finals it's entirely
objective that's subjective in the sense
if you do everything I ask of you you're
probably putting a floor on your grade
the floor would be a decent one B B+ so
basically if you just go check check
check check you've done everything
you're saying how do I get n show me
your creative show me a story show me
something that you know that the numbers
couldn't have down the way to think
about it think of your of a bot looking
over your shoulder with your name on it
a bot that actually can look at
spreadsheets fill in numbers just based
on mechanics ask yourself what can I do
that a bot can't do
that's what I'm looking for in fact if
any of you want to get chat GPT to value
a
company combine that with evaluation
because chat GPT will do all the
mechanical stuff right and then say this
is what I'm seeing in the story that
chat GPT did not so have no quals about
using AI to do an evaluation because
this is about you saying what do I bring
to the process because that's what the
real world is going to look like when
you get out there right so use whatever
tools you want but show me that those
tools
matter any other questions on the
project okay go
ahead you're way thinking way ahead pick
a company first worry about deliver it
will get done I've taught this class for
307 38 years it always gets done you say
I I can never value trust me I will drag
you across the Finish Line if that's
what I have to do by the end of this
class you will have valued The Company
You Picked and price the company some of
you might have gone through incredible
torture to get there but you will get
there that's my job so the deliverables
you know if you go on you you'll see
past projects so you can see what they
look like but you'll notice that the
format is all over the place because I
give people freedom in how they present
it my only rule is keep it short
you know why got to read all your
projects you now I grade all my stuff
exams quizzes and projects and if you
write 40 page projects I am completely
and totally screwed so there will be a
page limit I don't want you to write a
creative
novel let do the damn assignment which
is value the company price the company
tell me whether You' buy or sell that
shouldn't take you 50 pages if you're
lucky it might take you five pages so
six
pages yeah so keep it short because you
know and I will put a page limit
precisely for that reason so let's talk
about valuation this is the first set of
slides if you didn't bring them don't
worry it's the intro pack let's talk
about valuation so what I'd like to do
in today's class would talk first start
with a very simple explanation for why I
do valuation me start with a preface
most people who do valuation don't
believe in valuation
include most people Bankers analysts you
saying but they do valuation they do it
because it's their
job but if you ask them in a honest
moment why is Invidia trading at $105
per share why did the price drop by 800
billion their answer is because that's
what the market thought should
happen if I believe that I couldn't
teach this class so I'm going to start
by explaining why I teach valuation I
teach valuation to fight the laming in
me of leming leming became famous or
inFAMOUS in the
1950s when either National Geographic or
Disney you know the parentage is kind of
haziest who did this filled the most
amazing site thousands of big ugly
rat-like creatures gathered together on
a cliff ran right off the cliff into an
ocean and committed Collective suicide
and ever since one of the big questions
why did they do it what led them off I
don't know the answer to that question
but let's do some virtual imagery let's
say you were the first
leming Cliff comes up you didn't know it
was coming you go off the cliff you go
to the ocean incidentally these guys
can't swim that kind of seals the deal
dead second leming too close the first
guy also slides off the cliff also in
the ocean also dead but I'd like you to
put yourself in the shoes of the very
last leming I know Lemmings don't wear
shoes but kind of hang in there with the
analogy you ready you're running as fast
as you can towards a cliff you've seen
your entire tribe disappear off that
Cliff I would think you'd have second
thoughts about what you were just
planning to do your left brain right
brain whatever Parts R say stop stop
stop don't do
it and then you hear this voice in the
back of your head you know what it's
saying they must know something that you
don't remember those seven words in
investing in valuation they must know
something that you
don't so let's say you value inia you
beat me to the punch you value this
way you come up with a value of $130 per
share stock is down to what 110
115 what's your rational side
saying you should buy the stock now
right but then you hear this voice in
the back of your
head they must know something that you
don't why all those people selling the
shares must know something that you
don't and when you hear that voice
magical things will start to happen to
your valuation you'll bring down the
grow rates increase the discount rate
130 become 120 become 115 you're with
everybody else don't fight it there's a
leming inside each in every one of you
dying to get out just let it out you can
divide the whole world of investors into
three groups of
lmics the first
group I call proud lemings I'm a leming
and I'm proud to be a leming they call
themselves momentum investors but that's
what they do right you know what
momentum investors do they look for a
crowd they join and you're buying I'm
buying you're selling I'm selling too
lots of proud lemings today selling
Nvidia why are they selling cuz
everybody else was selling wasn't that
they thought through what deep seek
would do to earnings and cash flows they
were just heading for the exit because
they see everybody else
heading amazing amount of investing is
momentum investing I can't pull off
being a proud leming the second group I
call Yogi Bear
lemings know you you heard of The Legend
of Yogi Bear lived in Yellowstone Park I
think was smarter than the average bear
Yogi Bear Lemmings think they're smarter
than the average leming you know what
they want to do they want to run with
the crowd to the very edge of the cliff
and last moment we are away admitted
you're tempted you get all the upside of
momentum but you'd have sold Invidia on
Friday because you saw the cliff
coming you at CNBC you think there are a
lot of Yogi be Lemmings out there right
they're all I mean especially after a
market correction they all get on and
they say I saw that coming you were on
every week for the last 6 months how
come you never mentioned it maybe it's
because you didn't see it
coming I'll make a confession I have no
idea where the cliff was coming I didn't
see this weekend coming on Nvidia I
would be lying if I said
otherwise I can't pull off being a Yogi
Bear leming so if he ask me to describe
myself that's me a leming with a life
Fest that's all I aspir to be let's face
we're all human beings we're going to
get caught up in the mood at the moment
moment if everybody's upbeat you want to
buy if everybody downbeat you're selling
you can't fight all that valuation does
is slow the process down for me the
reason I'm valuing Invidia is to slow
the
process is to see if my rational side
can mount an argument because my human
side is saying sell everything head for
the trench I mean head for the exits
right now everybody else is
doing so what's the end game for this
class I hope to throw you that life
verest that's what I hope you get out of
the Class A life verest that you can
hold hold on
to that outclass that crowd Behavior
because you're going to buy stocks the
crowd is going to change its mind and
you're going to feel the urge to run
with them and maybe this process will
slow slow you down so that you can do
the right
thing so with that set in place let's
talk about three misconceptions about
valuation that I cut I think cut to the
heart of almost everything that goes
wrong in valuation the first is that
evaluation is an objective search for
the truth that you're some kind of
scientist sitting there valuing
companies you know what feeds into this
big numerical models and computers you
sit in front the computer you start
entering numbers I'm being objective I'm
just entering numbers that's an absolute
lie every valuation is biased you know
why because when you walk in to value a
company you're already coming in with
preconceptions about that
company and those preconceptions are
going to find way into your numbers me
give you a very personal example I have
valued Microsoft every year since
1986 since their IPO for the first 28
years of their existence every time I
valued Microsoft I found it to be
overvalued you name the price overvalued
overvalued strange right one of the
great success stories of the 20 late
20th century I wouldn't have bought it
one step of the way I could give you
access to every single valuation I've
done of micro Microsoft and you could
dig through the numbers looking for
Clues but be looking in the wrong place
if you really want to know why I found
Microsoft to be overvalued all you need
to do is go out of that door take the
elevator up to the ninth floor walk to
my office the door's open walk in don't
take any of the stuff in there and look
around you know what you're going to see
you're going to see my MacBook
Pro my iPhone is with me my iPad is
right next to my MacBook Pro I think I
don't know whether I bought my airpods
out or not but they might be sitting
there I have an Apple
display and if you look towards the top
shelf I have my original Mac 128k that I
bought in the 198 I've been an Apple
user since 1981 and to me Microsoft is
always been the Darth
Vader of
Technology now if you're a Star Wars fan
let me be specific about which Darth
Vader I'm talking about I'm not talking
episodes 1 two three Anakin Skywalker C
boy Darth Vader I'm talking episodes 4
56 he's dressed always in black with a I
don't think he ever takes a shower he
has a strange
voice I have lots of bad thoughts about
Bill Gates and they all come but and
nothing to do with vaccines I just bad
thoughts about Bill Gates that preate
vaccines and they all come bubbling up
to the surface when I sit down to Value
Microsoft and guess what when I'm
looking to see to give them high growth
or low growth my response is who' buy
this rotten product low growth
high risk or low risk you're one virus
away from blowing up high
risk my biases was so deeply
entrenched that I was incapable of value
Microsoft and I've given a clue of
another company I always struggled to
Value right which
is Apple if my trouble with Microsoft is
I hate the company too much to Value it
my trouble with apple is I love the
company too much to Value it I valued in
my blog every year for pretty much every
year since 2010 if you go back and read
my first blog post on valuing Apple I
spent half the post telling people don't
trust me I love this company too much
that's all I can do I can't tell them
I'm going to be magically objective and
put that all to the
side so all valuations are biased and
the more you know about a company the
more You' read about it the more biased
you're going to get which is a RNA right
because what do you told to do go
research the company read what other
people think which is all good but at
the same time your biases are getting
inter
trenched you follow up on
that you tell me who pays you to do
valuation and how much you get
paid I'll tell you which direction the
bias is and how much the bius is I sent
you a test I don't know whether any of
you took a look I'm going to take you
through that test because this is a good
time to talk about biases and how they
play out you have no idea what I'm
talking about right you already stopped
reading my email so that's fine
I so let me open up the test because
it's a good way to see what what these
biases translate into
so I have to stop the share and start
the share again because otherwise I lose
the share so let's see so
ready none of what I'm going to ask you
is going to be technical but play along
with me because I think it's going to
bring home what I mean by
biases first if you think about where
biases come from
right they come from almost everything
you do the first is the subconscious
right when you think about a company
already in your mind the more you know
about a company already a good company
Bad Company great company amazing
company take a take a company you're
familiar with Nvidia Apple Amazon take
the mag 7 you already have some
preconceptions good or bad that Finds
Its way right there's a lot of hurt
Behavior everybody else thinks the
company is a great company it's going to
find it way if Jim Kramer yells out the
name of the company that's why you
picked it and you like Jim Kramer
whether you like it or not that bias is
going to shop the second is the power of
suggestion
is one semester where I actually had an
assignment in the middle of the class
which I've taken away where I gave
people an IPO to Value there were two
sections of class same so I gave them
both the same Prospectors the same IPO
with one group I said your job is to
assess what pricing you set for the IPO
and I left it at that the other group I
said your job is to assess the value for
this IPO and by the way people not I
think it's worth about 35 I just want to
see what would happen by just planting
that little seed so the valuations come
back from the IPO I put up histograms of
what people found the class where I
didn't mention 35 the distribution is
sented around
$20 the class where I threw in the 35
which I completely made
up the valuations all got centered
around
35 I tell managing directors this for
God's sakes when you ask your team to
Value company don't throw a number out
there and ask them to ignore it they're
not it's going to go into your bias and
thirdly and this is the most powerful
bias of all is the power of money when
you get paid to do a valuation stop
telling me your
objective he who pays the piper calls
the tune in valuation if you get paid
for valuation it's going to find its way
in the
buyers and the larger the amount of
money that's at play the more biased you
will get so we're going to do a little
exercise to see how buyers plays
up so let's say you're an entrepreneur
and I'm a VC so you come to me to raise
Capital everybody familiar how that
process works I raise Capital what do I
get in
return I've never been a VC you've seen
Shar tank right so basically you're the
founder I'm the VC I give you money and
you I get a share of your company so
when you value a
company for raising capital is your
buyers going to be to come up with a
higher value or a lower value
Lisa higher why because if you get a
higher value you have to give up less
for the company to to Mark or to one of
the other shocks so think of the V Shar
City so you and how you going to do that
you might to push up your growth rate
make you pretend but if I'm in the VC on
this other side what's my
objective is to take a zero off the
Eng to come up with the lower value
already you can see bias is going to
drive those valuations let's go further
let's say you're valuing your own
business and this is too soon in your
life but you've become successful you're
35 years old you built this great
business and now you want to part ways
with your spouse it won't go into the
reasons but this is going to go into
divorce court and you're soon to be exp
spouse is going to get half your
business you come to me as an appraiser
to Value business what do you want as a
number zero if possible because half of
zero is zero that way you can go to your
XOX and say my business is worth nothing
I'm a terrible manager I'm going to run
this business into the
ground you're in Appraiser for the owner
value a business for tax
purposes High number or low number do
you want to go you want to pay more in
taxes or less in taxes let me save you
this this this incredible choice if
you're struggling with that question
you're in the wrong class right you can
take a you know economics class about
fairness and you you want to that b this
is not the place to fight let's face it
you want to get away paying as little in
taxes as you can so you want to make it
valuations for tax purposes are often
absurdly low and if you're the IRS
you're going to push in the other
direction the only problem is the IRS is
too cheap to often hire the best experts
so you have better experts you might win
in this game but that's again
bias I know some of you are PL in fact
somebody during the break said they were
look looking at a salside equity
research job at
Oppenheimer person here
no let's say you go to work for sside
equity research you know how equity
research is structured right buy side
equity research is equity research for
firms like fider and the research you do
informs how a mutual fund or what stocks
are invested what do cide analysts do
they are given a sector to track and
they put buy and sell
recommendations and then people either
they offer it as a free service so if
you're sell side equity research analyst
and you're valuing a company to put a
recommendation on it are you bias
upwards or downwards or should there be
no bias in this
process let's say you push up the value
what do you do you put a buyer
recommendation right you push down the
value you're going to put a sell
recommendation which one of those is
easier to live with as a cide equity
research
journalist and tell me why why is a buy
easier to live what's your primary
source of speci information if you're a
sales equ research analyst it's a
company
right I know what what walking to that
Gray Line Between legal and illegal but
you're trying to get some special
information that's not in the
price minute you put a sell side sell
sell recommendation guess what happens
all your contacts look up you know that
buy recommendations outnumber cell
recommendations 10 to
one it doesn't surprise me the bias in
that process pushes you to come up with
a high number because you can it makes
your life easier as it sells
are if you're a buy side analyst and I
ask you to Value let's suppose I own a
million shares of
inedia I'm feeling little shaky today as
a portfolio manager you're my favorite
analyst can you value Nvidia for me
right
now and you would what's the what's the
the report I I hope to get from you what
will make me happy and what's going to
make me a little pissed
off I'm
sorry I get that life is so much easier
if I don't have to sell the stock right
so if you come back and say you know
what it looks under value oh thank you
God if you say it's overv value you're
creating a whole host of issues for me
because I now have to sell the stock
explain to my clients why I left the M
money in the table bias comes from the
fact that when somebody asks you to
value a company then not doing it with
this completely unbiased perspective
they' like a particular answer they
claim that they will be okay with an
honest answer but I'm reminded of that
Jack Nicholson line from A Few Good Men
you want you should watch the movie is
that the end you know Jack Nicholson is
this General in the Army he's covering
up some bad stuff and Court whoever it
is is saying you
know no this is the truth and Jack
Nichols
you cannot handle the truth and a lot of
people who ask for valuation advice
really can't handle the truth they want
an answer that they want to but if
you're a buy valuing a company for
somebody who shorted the
stock what do they want they want
confirmation again the world is full of
people wanting confirmation they don't
want the truth they want you to tell
them you're right that Finds Its way
into the
bias finally let's look at the m&a
process which in my view is the most
screwed up process on the face of the
Earth you're an m&a Banker working for
the aquir remember there are four four
players in the room in an m&a there's
the managers of the acquiring company
manages of the target company Banker for
the acquiring company Banker for the
Target company and there's a friendly
merger so let me ask you right off the
top who in that room doesn't want the
deal to go through first do the bankers
want the deal to go through yeah
absolutely both sides because that's how
you get paid
the manager of the target company might
want the deal to go through but the
manager of acquiring company also
because they want to dress it up and
said this is a great deal there's nobody
in that room who wants to be told that
this is not a good
deal already you can see why so many bad
deals go through there's no push back
because it's other people's money the
remember the manager of the company not
spending their money and if you're an
m&a comp Banker working for the Target
company you have a different challenge
you got to convince your share olders
that they're getting a great deal
because you want the deal to go through
it's actually interesting that the
bankers on both sides convince their
side that they're getting a good deal
how can a deal be a great deal for both
sides I'll let you work it out but this
is why people create magical words like
Synergy because that way both sides can
claim we're winning because in any deal
if you're getting a great deal I'm
probably not getting a very good deal
but somehow that magic works out in a
hostile acquisition though the game
becomes interesting the acquiring
company wants a deal to go
through the target company wants to stop
the deal so if you're the Investment
Bank of the target company what do you
have to do you have to show your
shareholders that the price being paid
is too low that they should turn down
the offer again there's
bias the acquiring company has this
tricky path which is they want to claim
that you're paying a higher price but
that you're still getting a good
deal m&a banking is where valuation
first principles go to die there's so
much bias in this process you might as
well strangle that valuation in its crib
because it doesn't deserve to get out of
there bias is endemic out there right so
when you think
about but bias in the game it comes from
all over incidentally what you saw there
was meant to be the start of the class
test but I wanted to get the project
thing you're going to see at the start
of every
class the start of the class quiz don't
worry it's not for for a grade and what
I'm going to test you on is what we're
going to cover in the next 80 minutes
you're say that is ass back backwards it
is meant to be and my objective with
these quizzes is to show you that you
already know the answers we're going to
come up with intuitively and that the
class is just going to fill it up so
first misconception about valuation it's
about buyas in fact let me tell you a
story about how buyas plays out in
valuation so about 30 years ago company
called ly broadcasting was then called
Lin cable AT&T had this option to buy
49% of Lin cable at an appraised value
that's why the option was read time for
the option to be exercise comes about
AT&T goes out and hires Morgan Stanley
so you guys are going to be Morgan
Stanley you work for the buyer what's
your job to assess the value of the 49%
so AT&T can pay it
Lynn broadcasting hired its own
Investment Bank Leman Brothers I'm sorry
to do this to you but think of
yourselves as pre- bankrupt Leman
brothers and you work for the seller and
your job is to assess the value of the
49% so Lyn can sell it so Morgan
Standley works for the buyer Leman
Brothers works for the
seller One Bank comes back with $105 per
share the other comes back with
$155 per share I want you to guess which
one came back back with 105 and which
one came back with 155 you guys be the
guessers who who came back with 105 you
think yeah and
why they work for the buyer your job is
to get the low ball number it's not that
they're doing a bad job but they're not
virtuous people they did their job and
Leeman brothers did their job in fact
the difference is so large they decided
to call in a third Investment Bank why
settle for two fees when you can have
three I guess and they call this outfit
called was parella I'm going to say
something incredibly harsh about these
guys but I mean every word of it these
guys couldn't value a $20 bill in a
brown paper bag if you put in front of
them they invent some multiple
Enterprise Value to cash in the bag next
thing you'd be paying $66 for a $20 bill
but if you're was parall you're right in
the middle here right you want to piss
off either side too much you got to work
with both sides in the future
10555 where's the safest place for you
to be $130 they came back with $127
50 I'm going to let you in on a little
secret evaluation that you shouldn't let
out of this room if you're ever asked to
Value something never ever come back
with a nice round
number don't tell me the Target price is
40 tell me it's
$388 it's amazing what that second
decimal will do in terms of creating an
illusion that you actually know more
than you do the intimidation Factor kick
said in most valuations the value gets
set first the valuation follows people
decide how much to pay and they look for
justification in my view m&a banking you
shouldn't even value companies you know
what the value of a Target compan is
it's whatever you've chosen to pay plus
$10 why do we torture young analysts and
make them run through spreadsheets for
two weeks to arrive at that conclusion
because that's exactly where you're
going to
be those number crunches you're going to
come back with the number and the
managing that looks a little low can you
run the numbers again there's an
implicit message don't run with the same
inputs try changing them and magically
when you get to $10 above the Target
price the questioning will
stop it's not that Bankers are bad
people the process is broken the
dealmaker is the deal analyst asking a
banker whether a deal makes sense is
like asking a plastic surgeon whether
there's something wrong with your face
what kind of answer do you think you're
going to get you're perfect already no
then there's nothing to do your nose
looks a little long your lips look a
little thin so basically that's my job
as a plastic
surgeon bias second misconception if I
do a good valuation I'm going to get the
right
answer when does that process get
started probably in kindergarten first
grade teacher puts a problem in front of
you my wife teaches first grade 2 plus
three you get five congratulations you
got the right answer you get any other
answer count your fingers again you know
because you counting on your fingers get
it right because you got the wrong
answer you must have done something
wrong and this process gets fed into all
and God help you if you end up in a
quantitative discipline engineering math
because then you get more reinforcement
if you do things right you get the right
answer you got the wrong answer you must
have done something
wrong my NBA class this morning asked
people the evaluation class I asked
about their
backgrounds a lot of recovery ing
engineers in that
room so the about half my class is Quant
people recovering Engineers
mathematicians
scientist the other half is no story
people and I I know exactly what's going
to happen Midway through the semester
many of the people in that number
crunching side and you can probably
self- select in this class as well which
side you're in we show up in my office
with the valuation done put it on my I
said I'm done with my valuation can you
take a look and tell me whether I got
the right answer and I'll predict what
you know if you did that I'll tell you
exactly what's going to happen I'm going
to push the evaluation across the desk
back to you and say I don't know what
the right answer is and your faith in
the system is going to crack so you're
teaching this class you don't know the
right value of every company if I knew
the right value for every company why
would I be teaching this class I'd own
my own island in Hawaii with a castle on
top of it
right but you can see the group Splinter
when I say that because half the people
can't handle the fact that there is no
right answer you know what happens to
them they become fixed income
people I let them go it's a nice healthy
recognition because with the bond it's
all given Right coupon matur might have
to worry about default risk but it's so
easy to live with not of this growth and
Ai and all that stuff you don't
care and that's healthy you've left the
space the other half says this is kind
of neat you don't know what the right
answer is I can never ever convincingly
be wrong think about that that's one of
the great thing about
equities you you don't know the right
answer is I can't prove that you're
wrong no matter how outlandish your
number is I like that but for some
people the psychological barrier of
getting not knowing what the right
answer is it's tough and you will find
this when you value the company say how
do I know I'm right and the more of a
number cruncher you are the more that's
going to stress you out and all I can
say is just let it go right because you
can never check your answer you got to
be okay with
it and the the the addon to this
proposition is the more uncertain do you
feel about your answer the greater the
payoff to doing
valuation about 5 years ago when I was
teaching this class 2019 there was a
week in March where two companies went
public in the same week and I'm sure
you've heard of both companies the first
company was a company called Lyft Lyft
was the first right sharing company to
go public it predated Uber so you guys
are going to Value
left later in the
week a second company went public whose
name also start with L Levi
Strauss Levi Strauss didn't go public
till 2019 Levi stra has been around 150
years used to be public in the last
century went private but was going back
public so you guys are going to Value
Lei
straps you go to work you value which of
these two companies if you define
prision as your measure of quality which
of these two companies are going to be
able to Value more
precisely and what is it about Levis St
that makes it easier to Value go
ahead but even matter do you know how Le
St makes money right if you're confused
no point your back towards a mirror and
if you're wearing jeans there's probably
a 501 in the back it's made money on
it's a business model that we can see we
know it's long history we know a great
deal about the compan it's easy to Value
conversely lift is a business where
nobody's figured out how to make money
terrible business but lots of
potential it's going to be difficult
value not because you're not using the
right tools or you're not coming with
the right cost of capital it's a lot
more uncertainty so if I measure
valuation quality based on Precision
Levi St is going to win hands down
but which of these two companies do you
think the payoff to doing valuation is
greater why was LE STS easy to Value
because you a lot of history you knew
the business you think you're
special everybody has exactly the same
information right it is easy to value
for in fact you probably don't even need
people to Value Chachi PT could value
Nei St and do about as good a job as you
can lift on the other hand you know what
people do they give up
you'd be surprised how many VCS I run
into who've never valued a company ever
they price companies but they can't
value company they can price per user
price per subscriber and you ask them
why they say there's too much
uncertainty and I don't get that when
you value a company in the face of
uncertainty you have an advantage
because most people are not even trying
now is the time to Value Nvidia not six
weeks from now when things have settled
in so if you ask me for advice on what
company to Value I'm going to brush you
off with then I'm going to tell you to
go where it's darkest find a nice
Ukrainian Mining Company to Value
incidentally there are no nice Ukrainian
mining companies but my point is go
where it's most uncertain value Russian
company lots of uncertainty coming in
every possible Direction because I will
wag there is a single investor in the
world who's actually trying to Value
Russian companies right now they're
playing the pricing game but they've
given up go where it's darkest where
there's most uncertainty third
misconception about valuation if I make
my model bigger it's going to get
better we give away how old I am you can
check out my everybody knows how old you
are you can check when you were born in
Wikipedia no point hiding it but I'll
tell you a little bit about what I used
to value my first company
1981 I wanted to value a
company I had to write to the company
with a fountain ped now to the
investment relations officer can you
please send me an annual report
I sent it snail
mail and to give the company credit two
weeks later in the
mail I get an annual report I try to
explain this to my kids and they look at
me like I have two why don't you just go
online 1981 there was no online to go
into you don't remember a world where
that was true that was the case so I get
the annual report and I sit down with my
tools in front of me and here's what I
had in front of me I had a ledger sheet
you know what a ledger sheet looks like
just a blank sheet of paper with lines
drawn and that was a great Innovation
for me because I always got the lines
crooked this the lines came drawn but
it's an empty
sheet there's a calculator to my side
not a slide rule I'm not that old and a
pencil I learned very early in my
valuation life don't use a
pen that's what I use to Value today if
you sit down to value a company you
have data more this week when I want to
Value Invidia I'm going to go on Capital
IQ and I sent you that that that link
take advantage of it it's an incredible
database I can download the financials
for NVIDIA every year through its entire
history it'll take about one minute come
into an Excel spreadsheet nice I've got
the entire financials if I want to spend
extra two minutes I can download the
financials for every Semiconductor
Company while I'm
there in 3 minutes I can collect data
which would have taken me months if at
all to collect elect in
1981 and today of course I don't use a
calculator in a paper I use an Excel
spreadsheet it's a tool it saves me a
lot of trouble but the here's the
downside though when I did my valuation
on a ledger sheet you know how many line
items there were in the
valuation as few as I could get away
with do you see why because every single
cell had to be hand calculated and
written in adding an extra line item you
had to think long and hard about do I
want to break that into more detail and
you did it if you had to but you didn't
have to you said why am I going to
compute 30 more cells today you're in
Excel you want to add a line item it
takes you this long you write a macro
you have 50 more line items and you
carry this logical limit you have
banking spreadsheet valuations I don't
know how many of you worked at a bank in
the summer but a bank banking valuation
spreadsheet like a hyra the monster not
the you know it's like 15 worksheets
connected together hundreds of line
items and the and the selling pitch is
more detail creates better estimates of
value don't think so two things happen
with these gigantic spreadsheets the
first is you're not sure who's running
who are you running the model or is the
model running you there's a time in the
day where that power shifts around 10:00
at night the model starts asking you to
do things
go get me a cup of
coffee I don't want the model to get mad
at
me you'd be amazed at how many valuation
reports I read where the analyst says
the model valued the company at you know
what the analyst is saying don't blame
me I fed numbers into this gigantic
spreadsheet something happened in the
middle I have no idea there all these
worksheets that are connected the value
popped out on the other
side I'm going to give you an Excel
spreadsheet I don't want to make this a
class where you build Excel spreadsheets
from scratch that's a different class
that's an Excel class you can take I'm
going to give you an Excel spreadsheet
it's not rocket science spreadsheet
which basically values any company
you're free to use that spreadsheet in
fact I would encourage you to use the
spreadsheet because it saves you this
the model building exercise on one
condition the condition is when you turn
in your final report here are the words
I don't want to say that deoderant model
valued the no no no no no no no no don't
try to pass the buck on me for why
you're buying or selling a stock make
the model your own adapt it modify it
I've never written a macro in my life
there are no protected cells it's going
to be easy to change and modify if you
want to make it your
spreadsheet because you can mangle some
really simple assets using complex
models keep it
simple I've never valued a company with
more than 12 line
items I don't add detail unless I feel I
can bring some something to that detail
so with that in mind let's talk a little
bit about the biggest challenge
valuation because basically I've talked
about three things right bias I've
talked about uncertainty and I've talked
about
complexity we live in a world where
you're going to have jobs you asked to
Value companies and whether you like it
or not if you have a job somebody's
paying you there is always going to be
bias in the
process you're going to face uncertainty
do we face more uncertainty now than 40
years I think so I think globalization
has basically you know created this
world where we're all connected at the
heaven so China goes through a crisis
you're going to feel the pain in your
store in your valuation more complexity
more
uncertainty and we are creating a world
where it's easier to build these complex
models and I what I call the Bermuda
Triangle evaluation you the mythology of
the Bermuda Triangle right it's
supposedly this triangle in the Atlantic
where ships then planes disappear into
the Bermuda Triangle valuation is where
Good Sense
disappears when people talk about what's
going wrong with the valuation they
think it's some technical detail that
they're not getting the cost of capital
right the cash flows are wrong most
valuations go wrong because of one of
these three factors not because of the
technical details in how you do
things so I'm going to set the table for
the rest of the class there are only
three ways you can put a number on a
company
the first is an intrinsic valuation what
do you try to do in intrinsic valuation
you value an asset or a business based
on cash flows growth and
risk second is pricing we attach a
number to an asset based on what other
people are paying imagine playing seat
geek with stocks we ever use seat geek
you want to buy ticket in a section of
Yankee Stadium how do you decide how
much you pay you go to seat geek you
look at what people are charging for
prices they actually help you out right
amazing deal great deal good deal if you
ever use seat gig you it's a it's a
it's a great exercise in pricing because
the way they make that judgment is by
comparing the prices across different
deals pricing and the third approach is
there are some businesses where there's
optionality where there is we talked a
little bit about this in the first class
a pharmaceutical company working on a
drug that's working its way through the
pipeline an oil company with undeveloped
oil reserves that are expensive today
there is an optionality where if things
happen these companies could become
value that's the real op options
component people will tell you there are
hundreds of ways to Value companies
that's not true there are only three
approaches there are a lot of sub slices
Within These but ultimately it's got to
fall into one of those three buckets so
let's start with what all of these
approaches implicitly assume about
markets Lisa was in my office just
before and i' would encourage you guys
to drop by and just say hi and Lisa do
you remember the question you asked me
about markets what is the question you
asked are markets perfect it's the
question she
asked and if I said yes to the
question this class would be kind of
pointless right because what's the best
estimate of invidious value just go look
up the price right in an efficient
market this whole process would be
pointless because the market price is
the best estimate value and that's
actually not a bad null hypothesis the
market is doing a reasonably good job
but the minute you use an approach
whether it's pricing or intrinsic
valuation to tell me that a stock is
cheap you're implicitly also saying what
that the
market makes
mistakes that's the easy part because
everybody will agree and that you can
find those mistakes you can have the
first and not the second
right so as I describe these approaches
I'm going to talk about what you must
think about markets or believe about
markets for you to take do intrinsic
valuation as opposed to price say why
would I use one of it depends on where
you think Market mistakes happen and how
they get
corrected so let's start with intrinsic
valuation or the version of it that you
most often see in practice which is a
discounted cash flow
valuation it's not magic the value of an
asset is the present value of the
expected cash flows in the ass does that
sound familiar probably in the very
first finance class you heard this
somewhere along the way
right that's basically what this
accounted cash flow valuations
philosophically what are you trying to
do you're trying to estimate the
intrinsic value of an asset a business a
cash and already you can start to see a
debate Brewing is there a thing called
intrinsic value can you prove there's
one I can't that's why I call it
Faith it's like a little bit like the
search for the Holy Grail how long have
people been searching for the Holy Grail
I think thousands of I think Indiana
Jones came really close in this first
movie but nobody's found but we keep
looking and looking that's what we try
to do in intrinsic valuation we keep the
faith but it does require Faith you're
trying to estimate intrinsic value and
if you look at what goes into a
discounted cash flow model no matter how
complicated and complex you try to make
it you'll see a life for the asset
expected cash flows over that life and a
discount rate that reflects the risk in
the cash
flows there's no rocket science nobody's
going to win a Nobel Prize for saying I
found discounted cash flow valuation
it's always been there
but if you think about the kinds of
Market mistakes you need to make money
with discounted cash flow valuation
first you have to assume markets make
mistakes second you got to assume that
your discounted cash flow model is
allowing you to find those mistakes and
that's a dangerous assumption because
what's a track record of most people who
claim to find market
mistakes or let me rephrase the question
remind me again what the average
active fund manager beats the market by
every year
minus one and a half% it's the strangest
profession on the face of the Earth it's
like having a plumbing business called
floods or us and here's what you do I
have a leak in my house I call you and
you leave a flood and you then send me a
bill how long would you stay in business
not very long but that's what active
money managers do right you can
effortlessly beat them by 1 and half% by
buying an index fund they say trust me
send me your money I'll take a
management fee and I will deliver 1 and
a half% less than the index fund okay
okay let me send it out right
away but let's say you're special you
can find that market mistake let's get
the mistaken name Nvidia after today you
value the company at30 the Stock's at
110 whatever it turns out to be it's the
third assumption you need to make money
we talked about this the price has to
adjus to
Val so when you do intrinsic valuation
you seee markets make mistakes that you
can find those mistakes and the market
corrects its mistakes so how do you make
the market correct its mistakes so you
let's say you buy Invidia what you do go
on Facebook and write Nvidia is cheap
Nvidia is cheap Nvidia is cheap Nvidia
is cheap tweet out Nvidia is cheap buy
it now you can do everything you want
but the odds are that it's just going to
go into the noise and nobody
cares this is I think what makes
investing frustrating you can be right
and go bankrupt being right your
neighbor can pick stocks based on
astrological signs and end up making
millions of dollars why did you buy
Invidia because the stars are aligned
where's the cash flow no stars are
aligned that's all that matters right
it's not fair but it is what it is so
I'm going to leave you with the final
page when you think about why we do
intrinsic valuation your biggest
Advantage is it forces you to think
about the business right you cannot
value inedia without understanding the
business there's an old Buffet saying
that he doesn't buy shares in a company
that he buys pieces of business if you
subscribe to that intrinsic valuation is
fee second it is going to make you
understand that you're buying a set of
cash flows even if everybody
else so when you think about the reason
why people do intrinsic valuation it's
because these pluses the minus of course
is it does require a lot of
inputs it does also mean that if the
market Market correction doesn't happen
you're stuck with the stock that never
delivers money and if your job requires
you to be fully invested in stocks which
is what a mutual fund job is what if you
do intrinsic valuation every stock you
value turns out to be
overvalued you won't last very long as a
fund manager so next session when we
talk about start we will start with why
people like
pricing and why some people might be
able to get this Direction part under
their
control so I will leave you with that
I'll see you on Wednesday
right